hey guys what's up welcome to another
HTT tutorial and in this video I'll be
showing you I'm just giving you a little
guys giving that's a little trick here
showing you guys as you can see about a
title you can explore different planets
including Mars and the moon in Google
Earth 5.0 now if you haven't already you
can go ahead and watch my video on how
to download and install the latest
version of Google Earth which is 5.0 and
you'll be able to enjoy all these
features so the first thing I want to
say as I open up the Google Earth here I
apologize if it's free me at all it will
be a little bit Frei me because I'm
running on Google Earth and Camtasia
Studio 6 at the same time but basically
all you have to do in order to discover
a new planet or there's only a few but
you already see the earth here and it's
obviously that is Google Earth in the
first place what you can do is go up
here to this planet button and you can
switch between the earth the sky and the
planet Mars so I'm gonna hit the Mars
button here and you can watch this
animation again it'll be a little free
me but you can watch as we go and move
over to explore the planet Mars
so um it'll take a few seconds actually
in the first place I've noticed but it
has to load the entire you know the
entire planet so I let's wait for this
to finish and there we go there's Mars
now it's it's not going to be quite as
detailed as Earth is obviously because
we don't live on earth and we're not
discovering new things every day but you
can obviously use a lot of the same
features on that you would in Google
Earth in Google Mars or in exploring
Mars and Google Earth so what I'm going
to do you may have realized you can
obviously fly to different cities in
different places in Google Earth well
let's see this in our face on Mars and
there we go it's going to zoom in and
find us the face on Mars that legendary
face and everyone's talking about same
animations as Google Earth and there you
go so there's a lot of the features that
you could still use if you're exploring
Earth as you can see down the left hand
side different layers of travelers back
to Mars Rovers and Landers which
obviously have landed on Mars which is
pretty cool and other things that we can
obviously explore as well
so again there's a lot of cool stuff you
can find here in a different
applications I just figured I'd show you
guys this because I thought it was
pretty cool you can explore different
parts of Mars um in Google Earth it's
just like and you can click on it you'll
get a picture of it from the Mars
obviously from NASA's Mars rover so
that's pretty cool so yeah have fun
exploring Mars and Google Earth 5.0 if
you don't already have it link is in the
description and hope you enjoy exploring
Mars so thanks for watching this video
and please subscribe for more this